Chưa qua ngày 28 năm năm 2018, phòng cảnh sách nhiên sự công an tình án gạng cho biết
bát truyền án đã bác sữa hai đối tượng củaến thị kiêm hoa, sinh năm 2019, vàng
với vật lần, sinh năm 2019, cùng chua phỏa tây a, sá phụ thật, vệ thoại sân, tình án gạng
để tức tục đuí tra về hành viết người.
Chưa đó, sáng 18 năm 2019, người thân phát hiện ông trên đặc phòng, sinh năm 2019,
cùng chua phỏa tây a, sá phụ thật, vệ thoại sân, phó chủ tịch hội nông dân sát phụ thật, từ vong bất thử trong
phòng của tuy nhiêu ngày trước với nhiều vết thương trình cửa thiệt.
Ông phòng đã li gì vợ tương năm 2018, đặc sống một mình,
qua khám nghiệm sách định trên người nạn nhân có bố miếc chiến vết đầm chếm,
cười nhà không có dù vết kệ khóa, các mấy ra trong nhà sau bị ớt, trong nhà không có dù hiệu kệ phá,
lúc tình tài sản.
Nói vì vì bị sách hại thị ra định cho biết, ông phòng còn bị mất một tệ thoại dụng và một số dễ tự thân.
Căn cứ có khám nghiệp, lúc lượng phản rất định đầy là vụ án rất người.
Cô khám năng nạn nhân mù tấn kênh tụng tình ảy, nên đã vào trong phòng vụ của ông phòng,
có sự đường thận của ông phòng, sau đó sẽ ra mù tấn, ra tây sách hại nạn nhân,
bằng các biệt pháp biệt vụ đến tôi cùng ngày, lúc lượng công an đánh trong
xong xác định với thiết kìm phà là đối tượng ghi vấn, nên mời vì chủ sở làm việc.
Tuy nhiên, hoa tình làm cho công việc về sĩ, bảo vệ ở thành phố chiming nên có hiểu biết sả hội và có kếc đời phó với các quan đều chá,
hai chối quan có.
Tuy nhiên, chương nghĩ chính cứu, tại liệu bất chiếm tuy thập đục cho quá trình điều tra,
hoa thường nhận đã giả tay sách hại ông phòng.
Tuy nhiên, bác trình án nhận thấy lời khai của hoa còn nhiều đêm bố thấn,
bởi vì là phụ nữ nhiều hoa không thể một mình giả tay sách hại ông phòng,
với bố mi chiến phết đầm chếm, trong khi đó đã nhân lần người có su khỏe, to cầu.
Tính hành khám sách hình cấp nguy ở và nhá vườn của hoa, tu được nhiều hụp khi tình ghi.
Đặc biệt, qua chiếc sức cà mẹ ra tại nhá hoa phát hiện,
bò khoảng hướng 28 người mẹ 1 tháng năm 2018,
khoa trình bị hụp khí là dấu và bình xí thơi kê,
đi cùng với mụn người năm thêm nhân trong nhá hoa.
Lối tự tình ghi được xác định là nguyễn phần lần,
chóu của hoa ở chung trong nhá hoa.
Lần là đối tự không nghi nghiệp, chà mẹ li gì nhau,
lần ở với ông bản hoại là chà mẹ hoa.
Hí bị trự tập làm việc, lúc đầu lần khu tự hệ,
nhưng qua các tệ lựa chứng cứ tụt tập được,
lần đặc hai nhận tối hiểm mẹ 1 tháng năm,
qua dù lần cùng bị xác hại ông phòng.
Tuy nhiên,
hà không mại só cho lần biết về việc hoa tụt thức phong trong quan hệ tình cảm.
Hí đi,
hà và lần mang theo bà kê dào và mục biệt sị thơi kê.
Hí đến,
phòng ông phòng đống cửa,
hà đi và nói,
hế lâu ăn yêu,
sau đó,
hà và lần cầm vùng khi tình công liên tí bằng người ông phòng,
đến khi nạn nhân năm vụ trí dự.
Về an sông,
lần vào hà cầm vùng khi bỏ vào trong bỏ,
đêm về nhà vùng của hà cầm sống,
sau đó hà đi về nhà.
Hịt vụ ăn tí tục đu cha.